Breaking Free of the barriers and making
a run for it but this protester was soon
stopped by security guards removing him
from the path of racing horses they were
successful the track Invasion ultimately
an act of distraction rather than
disruption
and there was this failed attempt to
cause Havoc these two demonstrators were
arrested as they tried to breach the
fence and forced their way onto the
track the police were prepared with some
people arrested early in the morning
away from the event based on
intelligence reports
there was also a heavy police presence
on the ground I witnessed the arrest of
those two demonstrators and I heard one
officer tell colleagues to get the names
of anyone filming I explained that I'm a
journalist I was then repeatedly asked
for my date of birth I repeated that I'm
a reporter and one officer apologized
then another tried to read my notebook
clearly suspicious that I had some kind
of relevant information police today
were well aware of what happened at the
Grand National the race was delayed
thanks to members of the same group
animal Rising they insist their efforts
at Epsom didn't fall short of their
Ambitions do you worry at all that your
actions might be putting the horses in
danger we know that in UK racing a horse
dies every other day in May alone 20
horses died at the Grand National which
is another another race run by the
Jockey Club three horses died this year
what we wanted to do is just to create
this larger conversation so that regular
people race goers you know people who
were sitting at home can think about if
we love animals why is it that we
continue to support Industries like
horse racing that harm them
animal Rising also says the protester
who made it onto the track was already
there before the race began and the
event should have been delayed that is
disputed by the organizers
as for the spectators and punters many
were not impressed with being questioned
on their choice of entertainment
it's in their place
there was a high court in Junction in
place making this action illegal those
arrested could now face fines and even
prison a risk some are willing to take
to protest what they see as serious
animal cruelty in racing we've spent 40
million over the last 20 years to
improve welfare standards these horses
are born and bred in order to race that
is what they do without racing they
simply would not exist so animal
rising's agenda leads us to effectively
to the extinction of the thoroughbred
although there was also peaceful protest
today we can expect more extreme
attempts to disrupt races the tactics of
some demonstrators part of a growing
Trend whether the cause is animal rights
or the environment of dramatic and
sometimes illegal action Becky Cottrell
Sky News Epsom Downs racecourse